I want to focus on interest rates you
came here in July and I spent my five
minutes laying out reasons why you
should not then increase interest rates
my most gullible friends believe that I
was successful in persuading you and
hence that is the reason why interest
rates have not gone up I have some
valuable friends um but I want to keep
doing it um as I argued then back in the
summer God's plan is not for things to
rise in the autumn as a matter of fact
that's why we call it fall nor is it
God's plan for things to rise in the
winter through the snow God's plan is
that things rise in the spring and so if
you want to be good with the Almighty
you might want to delay until May um but
and I know they're a bunch of things
you're aware of many economists say we
shouldn't move forward now managing
director of the IMF has been fairly
candid we've got deflationary risk we
just have a bad growth report and you're
aware of it but you probably won't
estimate it as highly as I will because
of my occupation but don't underestimate
the ability of politicians in both
Europe and the United States to screw
things up I mentioned last time you hear
the psychological advantage to retirees
of nominal interest rates of four to
five percent so they can live on the
retirement savings without a nominal
invasion of principle that psychological
benefit is not in the GDP statistics in
fact you reduce to GDP statistics
because they're not going to
psychologists and spending money which
would be part of the gdp but it does
enhance the and then finally as I
pointed out to you and why would you
want to talk to you privately about this
how faz be is coming up with this new
two trillion dollar change that will
hurt construction to press the economy
other thing is that if you act too soon
and you decide whoops we acted too soon
you get
you put yourself in a position first
where you have a zigzag policy and you
will face criticism from that by some
people I know and second if you then
want to go in the other direction you
only got a quarter point to play with so
if you hit the brake too soon and just
say oops I gotta hit the accelerator you
don't have any guess um with that in
mind I'm concerned about the effect
raising interest rates now would have on
the real estate recovery and I would ask
you what you would think the impact
would be of raising interest rates on
the housing recovery and would we
squeeze creditworthy borrowers out of
the housing market and that and create a
negative feedback loop with prices going
down so you've made a very large number
of very good points and indicated many
relevant considerations that the
committee is trying to weigh in balance
and has been taking into account with
respect to the housing market of course
the level of mortgage rates is relevant
to housing but and so we're very aware
that for example is sharp rise and
mortgage rates could have a very
negative effect on housing we do however
have a recovering economy where
employment is going up income is going
up households are in better shape to
form households whether it's that
they're moving into rental properties
the Millennial seem to have a strong
preference for later house purchases but
we do envision gradual recovery in the
economy in the housing sector let me
come back to the point that I made
earlier which is the committee
anticipates a very gradual increase in
interest rates we're not envisioning
that when we begin to raise rates we're
going to be looking at a very steep path
of interest rates
that wouldn't cause the kind of harm
that you're worried about to the housing
sector so that whole path matters and
that is a gradual path time the time of
the gentleman has expired